bethniss harmonson that's
a big theme in recent usernames i've
seen to
include a play on both magnus and beth
harmon
jinan is asking why doesn't rapport play
tata steel
i wouldn't know usually the answer is
either he didn't get invited or he
turned down
an invitation as for rapport i think
or at least from what i've heard from
him
from what he tends to say with teammates
in this bun club in the days when people
still used to play
he's not that eager to play chess he
does enjoy
playing in china a lot other than that
he usually
i don't think he's that that eager to
play
all of the big events so i'm i'm not
sure what happens if he was asked or if
he didn't turn down but
if he did turn it down but those are
usually the options
here we go
as for this position this is good for me
because he's gonna struggle to get
all the pieces out in time and i'll just
go for some
direct stuff usually this exchange on d4
opening up my
light square bishop is not
helping black
and yes all right tough queen c5 i
assume i can
take and then go knight c7 and queen b6
worst case scenario i can just grab this
pawn
hmm
rogue or night now just take with the
rook
foreign um
i don't know i was trying to do
something smarter than just taking it
that's really no particular reason to
overthink this
now knight d7 was somewhat where it is
strong i'm still winning but
knight d7 rook d6 knight c5 and i
thought some knight b3
could be a bit of an issue but
let's not get too clever
okay this is
basically over two pawns up and
i might my queen one of them
some debate about rapport's rating being
inflated
i don't know i think he's tremendously
talented i don't know about his track
record
or talent is always a stupid word like
as i said i don't believe
i do believe more in the world nurture
part than in the nature part
he's tremendously creative is maybe a
better word he has a
completely different approach how he
thinks about stuff
than the rest of the top and i i find it
very interesting
um i don't know i haven't checked his
results against
the world
world elite what's his rating is 2750 in
that neighborhood
generally i i believe writings don't lie
but yeah i haven't i haven't done any
stats
i'm assuming has he he's played some
vikes no how is it done
now i'm a rapport fan
all right thanks for the game bethnis
harmerson